and hurricane durian is taking its last
shot at the US this morning after
marching through the Caribbean and up
the southeast coast and causing at least
30 deaths in the Bahamas North Carolina
is the target of Dorian's wrath this
morning you can see violent winds
ripping into the American flag on North
Carolina's frying pan Shoals Dorian was
downgraded to a category one overnight
but it's less than 20 miles off the
coast with powerful winds it's causing
life-threatening flash floods and up to
6 feet in storm surge Omar Villafranca
is in Kitty Hawk North Carolina on the
northern part of those barrier islands
Omar what are the conditions where you
are
well good morning Tony we were actually
under a tornado watch for most of the
night that attention is now shifted
because the winds are starting to pick
up here and we're also starting to see
bands of rain come in now these people
who live here who have got coastal
property they know what's coming on the
way but here's the part that people are
concerned about you can look at the sea
right now and it is starting to come up
here pretty good we're expecting about a
foot of rain but as much as 6 feet of
storm surge in any meteorologist will
tell you while the wind is impressive it
is of course the storm surge that causes
the most damage and can kill the most
people now homes and businesses people
here they were ready they boarded up
their windows they sandbagged their
doors they also you don't see a lot of
outdoor equipment here they picked it up
and moved it in they don't want it to
become a flying projectile another
interesting note there is a curfew here
and nobody can go in and out of Dare
County mandatory evacuation order with
the sheriff and the police departments
are basically telling us if you're here
you are riding the storm out you don't
have any other choice they've cut off
access because like I said they're
worried about this sort of storm surge
coming up and as the morning goes on
that that's what they are expected
another interesting thing everybody who
lives here low-lying area they know what
to expect I talked to one man who said
he's gonna ride it out despite all the
warnings that we've been doing all week
because he said honestly he doesn't have
any other place to go so an interesting
thing to see if there's any luck in this
guys it's that the
tourist season is over so there's not a
lot of people here we're gonna have to
watch the conditions here and see as
they get worse throughout the morning
drink up
all right Oh mark thank you so much